[Music]
to me diversity means inclusion and when
I say that I mean full inclusion because
with full inclusion you're going to get
the best quality of output from anything
that you're dealing with the friend of
mine says you know Michael you weren't
the first homosexual PNG but you sure
did put a public face to in the 80s and
it's true you know I think that
description is right I look back on this
whole thing I think God you one crazy
queen what drove me ahead I'm a fighter
and certainly the time that I've been
gay and has not been easy
[Applause]
[Applause]
if you don't know the history you're
gonna repeat you know the famous line
you're gonna repeat it so I think that
that's the key it's important to
understand the struggle because the
truth is were always in astronomy
[Music]
okay so someone came to me about six
months ago
and they said hey you know the 25th
anniversary of P&G including sexual
orientation into its diversity
statements coming and we'd like to make
a big deal of it I started thinking
about it over the past 25 years we've
made an incredible amount of progress
towards inclusion but our current times
remind us it can be lost very quickly
and so a little light bulb went off in
my head I thought well something had to
happen in 1992 companies just don't make
that shift as particularly at that time
I reached out to the LGBT employees and
asked is anybody remember what happened
one person wrote back and said I think
it had something to do with the
mouthwash called paradox I called our
archivist and said paradox what is it
how do would it possibly connect they
came back and they said well we owned it
we can't find any connection we don't
have much on it at all so dead end I
emailed back again who knows something
about paradox and one guy wrote back and
said a friend of mine may have been
involved in it his name is Michael Janek
oh boy
Cincinnati in the 80s I got there in 78
conservative I mean you know
Cincinnati's roots yes really a large
cow town if the world were coming to an
end you'd want to be in Cincinnati
because it wouldn't happen here for
seven years after it happened everywhere
else progress and moving things forward
wasn't something that the the community
as a whole seemed interested in I didn't
go to Pride until about 85 because going
to Pride was in fact coming out you know
that's a like going to the cotillion
your coming-out party another parade
wound going for hours a spectacle even
Barnum and Bailey
like envy because there was so much
discrimination and there were so many
problems you had to make friendships
they had to be good friendships and so I
met some of the old-timers and got
involved in different political groups I
started a PNG in April of 85 and I
really was a lab tech in the
old-fashioned sense the word it was a
aant person administrative technical
yeah there's a lot of things in the work
place and everything you saw there was a
lot of homophobia there was a lot of
sexism but that's how most people
thought then you know it was kind of a
risky thing being known escape that I
mean in those days it was kind of a
friend of a friend sort of thing like an
old secret society
was isolating because we can talk to
each other there was that fear that was
that isolation and then the rest of the
people you could talk to you there was
potential judgment I went to that Pride
Parade in 86 I ran into my friend Bob
McNee I liked Bob it was great to see
him it was a celebration in those days
she didn't see gay people you know I
mean 200 people in a town the size of
Cincinnati Gay Pride 1986 these are like
your brothers and sisters here this is
all homecoming week Bob and I can stand
when the local TV station caught that it
was on Saturday and it was on Sunday
night and they it was even damn on
Monday night and that was really my
coming out at work a lot of people
stopped by this that morning about 30
people really and the message was
clearly you have to be careful Michael
you have to be careful after being in
that picture with Bob McGee at the pride
thing I think something snapped you just
finally say to yourself
screw it I was the authentic Michael I
was gonna be who it was it's either
gonna take you or you're gonna take it
and I had made up my mind and our guest
today is Michael Janek noted interviewer
and leader in the gay community he was
willing to be an outlier he wanted to
change for the better he was willing to
put it on the line he didn't sugarcoat
things
I've often been a target of a lot of
nasty stuff over the years
I'm not here to justify are not
justified but I do feel that I've heard
a lot of stuff about a lot of you and I
think it's our own hatred of ourselves
it keeps us at each other so much and
we're so smart and yet so willing to
believe some very strange things and
sometimes that's disappointing I guess
we all come out we look for community
and find out that that's a very
difficult concept
I had my debut in June of 86 on the
local TV station and by the end of the
year I'm transferred to the paradox
brand once I understood what they were
trying to do I thought well I got
something to offer here I was 23 years
old and they put me on this tiny little
brain called paradox that was on
no-one's radar screen it's a
prescription mouthwash and it was
prescribed by dentist oral surgeons and
periodontist with an FDA indication for
gingivitis they started seeing market
share for paradox really going up in San
Francisco and Boston and ways that were
kind of out of proportion Center for
Disease Control says nationwide AIDS has
struck 1641 mostly homosexuals 644
people have died from the mystery
disease actually refused to see patients
for their HIV started us being called
grid gay-related immune deficiency and
then subsequently it became more
generally known as AIDS but by the time
people were aware of what it was it was
too late because there weren't effective
remedies then
Proctor and Gamble really found this
niche with paradox being used by people
with AIDS with a pharmaceutical you have
to be able to market with whatever it's
indicated for through the FDA so we
didn't have an indication for what was
called or candidiasis it's basically
known as thrush and many people with
AIDS would struggle with that quality of
life in terms of nutrition you know
swallowing just that basic what made a
good day or a bad day became more
prominent because of the acquired immune
deficiency syndrome or AIDS is unknown
and there is no known cure
you had a life span of six months maybe
18 months if you were lucky if you can't
eat you die quicker that's the bottom
line and if there's something that was
better than the current treatments then
it was worth pursuing we were doing
qualitative research in the form of
focus groups and one-on-ones and going
to doctors that were prescribing it it
was a way for us to both learn more but
also just be in community and have a
conversation with 30 people in a church
basement or community center they were
able to share their experience and how
it worked or why it worked if we are
marketing this product whether
indirectly or directly to people with
AIDS and then
affecting the larger LGBT community then
we need to hold ourselves to the same
standard
there was this disconnect you know they
want to do the science they want to do
the marketing but they didn't quite get
because they weren't gay the piece that
these are people's lives and these
people are right here even inside of
this company
the first mistake he can make when it
comes to dealing with Queens if you're
gonna sell him something you better damn
well claim him I had to say that message
many many many many times before I
finally found a few people that said you
know you're right Michael knocked on my
door came in on these very affable guy
he told me that that things were not
good for the LGBT community in in PNG
there was always these programs of
budding even then there were programs
about inclusion but those were for
Asians those were for Hispanics I
pointed out well there's no you know
where are the gays
where are the lesbians I went and had
these face-to-face talks and I finally
got it out of the guy well we didn't
include them we don't have to include
them we're not gonna include them that's
that's the kind of atmosphere it was
they were not ready to embrace that they
were not wanting to embrace it I didn't
realize that he was getting kind of
harassed getting some some letters that
were we're not very pleasant this one is
marked confidential opened at a time you
have 30 minutes to one hour he had a
specific interval the time
and this is the Romans mapped to heaven
the truthful Bible road to heaven from
the book of Romans Mike I was told about
what some saw on TV I don't judge you I
know you have torment but my Lord still
heals and he cares for you and he will
make away from which there appears no
way out have faith and my all-time
favorite with a cartoon gay but not
happy we understand we've been there but
Jesus has set us free
God makes a way when there is no way I'd
walk down the hall and get called [ __ ]
by some folks that's that's the work
environment the issue that Michael was
most concerned about was seeing the
words sexual orientation right alongside
all of the other legal prohibitions
against discrimination in the EEO policy
statement P Angie wanted to be not only
lawful but doing the right thing but
doing the right thing went beyond the
law over the next four years we tried
every year we'd run it up the flagpole I
was constantly gathering information
what other companies were doing as far
as the gay issue the impact of gays in
the marketplace you know what this
really represented to them
the first recommendation we wrote was
just to put it in and talk about what
others were doing how diversity was
important and if we were going to say it
we had to live it I don't think it got
all the way to the CEO I don't think it
got out of our department to change the
policy required a business justification
paradox was of a prescription mouthwash
that allowed us to build a business case
that you know in my words you know
what's going to tip the scale
this is what we need to do as a brand as
a business and absolutely for our own
employees
[Music]
paradox was the key but it wasn't enough
this is what we were told because it was
not yet part of the federal mandate why
would we go further I can see Michael
and hear his words now tell me again
that the EEO has gone up and that we
were not include how much energy you're
going to invest of your soul to work at
a company that doesn't support who you
are
P&G was talking about diversity on the
one hand and how diversity was the
strength of the company it just wasn't
happening it wasn't in their mindset it
wasn't in their in their wheelhouse of
reality it's not that they're hateful
people is just outside of their sphere
when you're not gay you're not a woman
you're not a person of color you can sit
back and say you know of course we don't
discriminate and the fact is they're not
in that position to experience
discrimination P&G wanted to make sure
no issues were going to arise so they're
going to be any backlash from our
consumers from other employees from you
name it every attempt we had to make
more a case they were still afraid to do
it so back we went again year after year
and again after year and again it seemed
like an eternity busy to change or be
change in no way was Michael Janet going
to back away months would go by and then
simply you'd hear no so we had to kick
it up a notch there's a saying in the
Bible about having the faith on muster
seek well here's my you know my faith it
will change I thought that we needed to
get our legal ducks in a row tom was
able to do that
then said that I think it will carry
more weight if the recommendation
originates in the legal division it was
important to me I was a gay man I had a
vested interest my goal was to to get it
approved and the other benefits would
flow afterwards but let's get the thing
in in place first we had to kind of rein
in the passion just stick with the facts
he had one shot at making this happen
there are cities and schools that are
requiring us not to discriminate on the
basis of sexual orientation from a
business standpoint or hurting ourselves
that was the perfect book to give us
more ammunition if we're not matching
our competitors we were probably losing
some good people that we should have
been losing you have to work up that
command chain and you have to have
people that believe it's the right thing
to do and there has to be reasons that
it's the right thing to do there has to
be stats and figures and what is the
consequence of not doing it this is a
matter of survival for our community
it went up through the ranks it went up
quickly I saw it when it came back and
there were three just agreed and then
the most important two letters of all
okay and it had ela after it that was
mr. arts ed arts it was a done deal
September 15th 1992 for those of us that
had touched it in any way for those of
us that were involved in diversity and
inclusion it was just a thrilling day
there was kind of like a silent smile on
our faces that whole day you know you
have that moment where you say oh my god
maybe you didn't really think it was
gonna happen and it did you know finally
and he just can't it's just a lot to
take in
[Music]
words matter
you know policies do matter making
something legitimate legal taking a
stand matters we didn't get everything
right and we certainly weren't the first
but what's important is that we got it
done and the lessons that we learned
then makes it so much easier to go
forward all of the work that Michael and
Ann and land and Tom did just to get
those two words into the EO statement
those two words had a profound impact
maybe not in the day after but in the
weeks after in the months after in the
years after they were the start of
everything proctors come to understand
that if you can't bring your whole self
to the workplace you're not gonna do an
effective job you're hiding something
you're holding something back
who you are
it's always important to understand the
past because it's instructive because
you learn from the techniques what the
issues were how they were dealt with
that gives you clue to the future
if the struggle isn't over now
[Music]
we didn't think about there being an
LGBT community is that probably should
have in hindsight as being a factor that
could make a personal either feel
welcome or not safe or not when this
started there's no way that they knew
what this would turn into I mean this
created a path for domestic partner
benefits it created a path for
transgender benefits it created a path
that you know ultimately has led to
marriage equality we're still on this
path this journey of having an
environment where everybody can be who
they are what they want to be is it's
only by doing that that we make progress
as a company or as a society it's those
Michaels of the world that helped to
create incredible change
[Music]
it'll change if you believe it will
change and you work for it that's my
philosophy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you